antoine bonjour alors les amendements à
la constitution proposés par as le
président russe doit être présenté
aujourd'hui à la douma on le disait
comment cela va-t-il se passer si oui
bien dans un premier temps et comme pour
tout texte de loi les réformes à la
constitution proposés par vladimir
poutine vont être examinés vont être
étudiées par le conseil de la douma il
s'agit d'un organe interne à la chambre
basse du parlement qui est composé du
président de la douma mais aussi des
chefs des différents groupes
parlementaires que composent la douma
ensuite dans l'après midi
dans l'après midi ce sera au tour du
comité de construction étatique et de la
législation d'étudier de discuter de ce
projet de loi c 2 étapes sont des
travaux parlementaires assez technique
mais obligatoire avant que le texte ne
passe en séance plénière d'ici
probablement quelques jours par contre
lors de la séance plénière d'aujourd'hui
sera examiné la création du poste de
vice-président du conseil de sécurité un
poste promis par vladimir poutine à son
désormais ex premier ministre dimitri
medvedev c'est donc aujourd'hui que
démarre le processus parlementaire de
modifications que le président russe a
promis d'apporter à la constitution
russe
merci beaucoup antoine gayraud pour
toutes les précisions